this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by Norton one of my favorite
lines by Terence Mckenna to sum up the
human man-machine story is that human
beings the goal of humanity is to
effectively turn ourselves inside out to
actualize the human imagination to
literal eyes the human mind with our
creativity to turn our tools these
technological scaffoldings as to turn
them into extensions of mind to expand
the boundaries of no kevin kelley
co-founder wired calls technology the
seventh kingdom of life the Technium
subject to the same evolutionary forces
human beings taking matter of low
organization we put them through the
filters of the human mind then we
extrude space shuttle's and wireless
communication
works and smartphones with the
Industrial Revolution transcended the
limitations of our muscles with the
digital revolution we transcended the
limitation of our
with the biotechnology revolution we
will transcend
biology by turning the software of life
into something that is programmable we
will upgrade biology with the nanotech
revolution we will transcend by pattern
atoms
individual space Oh physical universe
will become like the Pixar universe as
manipulatable and as fluid as the
digital cosmos is the physical cosmos
will be programmable at that point when
we've patterning atoms like this so
consider these implications consider
then the context in which this place is
mined in which this place is life you
know as Bucky fuller used to say life is
an anti entropic phenomenon life moves
away from entropy towards greater
self-organization greater patterns
upwellings of patterns and structure
this is life this is mine and as David
Deutsch said in his book the beginning
infinity if you look already at the
physical topography of a city that when
happen
that's a topography in which the forces
of economics culture intent have trumped
geology right like literally the forces
of mine create more physical
topographical change and the forces of
geology - trumped matter and as Ray
Kurzweil ended his
nificent book The Singularity is near it
turns out my friends
central after all we're not just a pale
blue dot our ability to create virtual
models in our heads combined with our
modest looking thumbs was sufficient to
usher in a secondary force of evolution
called technology we'll continue to
universe our fingertips having invented
the gods we can turn into them that is
the human story that is turning
ourselves inside out that is actual
izing the human imagination what is
within becomes without